I wrote a little song to remind you, Choice Hotels, gets you more of the experiences you value. The Cambria Hotels got it all. A rooftop bar, have a ball. Cocktails up here feel just right. Is Cambria your home made? Bring a date, your team, or even your mom. Book direct at choiceotails.com.
我写了一首小歌来提醒你，Choice Hotels 能为你提供更多你所珍视的体验。Cambria Hotels 应有尽有。屋顶酒吧，尽情狂欢。在这里喝杯鸡尾酒感觉棒极了。Cambria 是你的家吗？带上约会对象、你的团队，甚至你的妈妈。直接在 choicehotels.com 预订。
See you on the roof. You know the old saying, never put off until tomorrow, what you can do the day after tomorrow? Uh, yes, procrastination. No one feels good about it, but most of us do it at least occasionally. You might have a big work project that's due, you feel stressed about it, and suddenly you realize you can't possibly get started until you clean your desk. Then you need a snack, then maybe a quick walk to clear your head. Oh, and don't you need to finish solving wordle before you can tackle that job?
屋顶见。你知道那句老话吗，“今天能做的事，永远不要拖到后天去做”？嗯，是的，拖延症。没人会因为拖延而感觉良好，但我们大多数人至少偶尔会这样做。你可能有一个截止日期临近的重要工作项目，你为此感到压力，突然你意识到在打扫办公桌之前你根本无法开始工作。然后你需要吃点零食，接着可能需要散个步来清醒一下头脑。哦，而且在处理那项工作之前，你难道不需要先完成 Wordle 游戏吗？
Before you know it, hours have passed and you're right where you started and more stressed than that. ever. Why is it so easy to fall into this trap, even when we know better? According to some psychologists, the answer is not that people are lazy or have poor time management skills. Instead, research suggests that procrastination is a problem driven by our emotions, and learning to manage negative emotions effectively can help us overcome it. So why do people procrastinate? What tasks are they most likely to avoid. How does procrastination affect people's lives and their mental and physical health? Why is procrastination so tied up with guilt and shame, even though it's something nearly everyone does? And when we're faced with the temptation to put something off, how can we change
不知不觉中，几个小时过去了，你又回到了原点，而且比以往任何时候都更加焦虑。为什么即使我们明知不对，却还是这么容易陷入这个陷阱？根据一些心理学家的说法，答案并不是因为人们懒惰或时间管理能力差。相反，研究表明拖延是一种由情绪驱动的问题，学会有效地管理负面情绪可以帮助我们克服它。那么人们为什么会拖延？他们最容易回避哪些任务？拖延如何影响人们的生活以及身心健康？为什么拖延总是与内疚和羞耻感联系在一起，尽管这几乎是每个人都会做的事情？当我们面临推迟某事的诱惑时，我们该如何改变
our mindset and our environment to help us buckle down and do what needs to be done? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Fuchsia Sirwa, a professor of psychology at Durham University in the United Kingdom and author of the book, Procrastination, What It Is, Why It's a Problem, and What You Can Do About It,
我们的心态和环境，以帮助我们集中精力完成需要做的事情？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是英国杜伦大学心理学教授、书籍《拖延：它是什么，为什么它是个问题，以及你能对此做些什么》的作者福霞·瑟瓦博士，
published in July by APA books. She is a social, health, and personality psychologist who is broadly interested in how self-regulation, how we manage our thoughts, emotions, and behaviors affect our health and well-being. In addition to studying procrastination, she also researches perfectionism, self-compassion, gratitude, time, and loneliness. She believes in the importance of communicating psychological science to the public to improve people's lives and has been interviewed about procrastination for news outlets, including the Washington Post,
该书由美国心理学会出版社于七月出版。她是一位社会、健康和人格心理学家，广泛关注自我调节（即我们如何管理自己的思想、情绪和行为）如何影响我们的健康和幸福。除了研究拖延症，她还研究完美主义、自我同情、感恩、时间和孤独。她坚信向公众传播心理科学以改善人们生活的重要性，并曾就拖延症问题接受过《华盛顿邮报》、
the New York Times, and the BBC. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Cyril. Oh, thanks for having me, Kim. I'm really thrilled to be here. All right. Well, let's not put it off any longer. How do you define procrastination in your research? What's the difference between procrastinating and simply deferring something for another time? Is there a difference? There is indeed a difference. I want to start with a quote that a colleague and friend of mine who got me into this area of research, Tim Pitchell at Carlton University in Canada, one that he often uses to make the distinction between procrastination and delay. And procrastination is a form of delay. So we can say that, you know, all procrastination is delay, but not all delay is procrastination. And really what that means is
《纽约时报》和英国广播公司的采访。感谢您今天参加我的节目，瑟瓦博士。哦，谢谢你邀请我，金。我真的很高兴能来到这里。好的，那我们别再拖延了。你在研究中是如何定义拖延的？拖延和仅仅将某事推迟到另一个时间有什么区别？有区别吗？确实有区别。我想从我的一位同事兼朋友、带我进入这个研究领域的加拿大卡尔顿大学的蒂姆·皮切尔经常用来区分拖延和延迟的一句名言开始。拖延是一种延迟。所以我们可以说，你知道，所有的拖延都是延迟，但并非所有的延迟都是拖延。而这真正的意思是
that procrastination is a very specific type of delay. And how, you know, researchers in the field, how we define it so that we can go out and explore, you know, where are the consequences and causes of procrastination, we define procrastination as an unnecessary form. of delay. It's a delay that's voluntary. So it's not like there's an emergency. It's not like somebody pulled you off of what you were doing, right? So you've chosen to delay, and there's no really good reason to. And it's usually on a task that we said we're going to do. So we have an intention to do that task. You said, I'm going to do that. I'm going to clean out the garage this weekend. I'm going to write that report by Friday. And that's the other thing, too.
拖延是一种非常特殊的延迟。研究人员在这一领域是如何定义它的，以便我们能够去探索拖延的后果和原因呢？我们将拖延定义为一种不必要的延迟。这是一种自愿的延迟。所以这不像是有紧急情况。也不是有人把你从正在做的事情中拉走，对吧？所以你是选择推迟，而且并没有什么真正好的理由。而且这通常发生在我们说要做的任务上。所以我们有完成该任务的意图。你说过，我要做那个。我这个周末要清理车库。我周五前要写完那份报告。还有一点也是，
it's usually a task that held some importance. And I think that lays into the final part of the definition, which is that we engage in this type of unnecessary, voluntary delay of these intended tasks, despite knowing there will be negative consequences for ourselves and others. Most people procrastinate occasionally, but some people struggle with it more than others do. Do you know what percentage of people are chronic procrastinators to the point where it's really affecting their health? Yeah, it's a great question. And indeed, a lot of us can procrastinate, you know, just occasionally, which we would call sort of, you know, more of a situationally based procrastination.
这通常是一项具有一定重要性的任务。我认为这引出了定义的最后一部分，即尽管知道这会对自己和他人产生负面后果，我们还是会参与这种对既定任务的不必要的、自愿的延迟。大多数人偶尔会拖延，但有些人比其他人更受其困扰。你知道百分之多少的人是慢性拖延者，以至于这真的影响了他们的健康吗？是的，这是一个很好的问题。确实，我们很多人偶尔会拖延，我们称之为基于情境的拖延。
You might procrastinate in your health, but you may not procrastinate at work, for example. Or you may just do it from time to pine, you know, depending on the circumstances. And so some of the estimates, the rough estimates we've gotten for that versus somebody who procrastinates on a fairly regular basis, almost to the point where it's like part of their personality, right? we can almost look at it like a personality trait. That percentage of the population in student samples, for example, college and university students, it's estimated about 50% of college and university students procrastinate chronically, whereas anywhere between 80 to 95% procrastinate at least once or more, but not necessarily to a large degree.
你可能在健康方面拖延，但在工作中可能不会，例如。或者你可能只是偶尔这样做，取决于具体情况。因此，对于那些相当规律地拖延，几乎到了像他们性格一部分的人，我们得到了一些粗略的估计，对吧？我们几乎可以把它看作一种人格特质。在学生样本中，例如大学和学院学生，据估计约有 50% 的大学生是慢性拖延者，而 80% 到 95% 的人至少拖延过一次或多次，但不一定程度很深。
So it's actually quite high in college and university samples. when we shift over and we look at adults, you know, we're now out in the workforce, you know, they've got their degrees and they're out there, you know, just getting on with their lives, it's still fairly high in terms of the chronic procrastination. And again, estimates there range between 15 to 25%, which is still quite a few people who are really, you know, engaging in procrastination as a fairly regular way of dealing with tasks that they don't want to deal with. Well, the crux of your research is that procrastination is not, as so many of us think it is, a problem of laziness or poor time management.
所以在大学样本中，这个比例实际上相当高。当我们转向成年人时，你知道，他们现在已经进入职场，拿到了学位，正在过着自己的生活，在慢性拖延方面，这个比例仍然相当高。同样，估计范围在 15% 到 25% 之间，这仍然有相当多的人在处理他们不想处理的任务时，确实将拖延作为一种相当常规的方式。好吧，你研究的核心是，拖延并不是像我们许多人认为的那样，是一个懒惰或时间管理不善的问题。
Instead, it's a problem, as you say, of emotion regulation. So what does that mean, what does emotion regulation have to do with procrastination? So, yeah, I mean, there's a lot of myths out there about why people procrastinate and, you know, sort of the common wisdom out there is that, oh, you know, teach somebody to manage their time better and they're stopped procrastinating or give them better self-control or tell them they're lazy and crack the whip and get them going and that'll reduce it. And really, you know, that sort of perspective is more of looking at the symptoms of procrastination rather than the cause. And this is what you mentioned, emotions are at the core of procrastination. And this comes from a lot of the research
相反，正如你所说，这是一个情绪调节的问题。那么这意味着什么，情绪调节与拖延有什么关系？是的，关于人们为什么拖延有很多误区，而且普遍的看法是，哦，你知道，教某人更好地管理时间，他们就会停止拖延，或者给他们更好的自控力，或者告诉他们很懒，鞭策他们，让他们动起来，这样就能减少拖延。实际上，这种观点更多是在看拖延的症状，而不是原因。这就是你提到的，情绪是拖延的核心。这来自于很多研究，
that suggests that the type of tasks that we procrastinate on are ones that we don't enjoy. They're ones that we find unpleasant, aversive. And that can range the full spectrum from just simply boring to gut-wrenching, you know, nerve-wracking, and, you know, anxiety-provoking.
这些研究表明，我们拖延的任务通常是我们不喜欢的任务。它们是我们觉得不愉快、令人厌恶的任务。这涵盖了从仅仅是无聊到令人揪心、令人紧张和引发焦虑的整个范围。
So anywhere along that spectrum of a task that makes us feel that in these negative emotions in one form or another, those are the tasks that we're more likely to procrastinate on. And so when we look at procrastination then in terms of emotion regulation,
因此，在任何让我们产生这种负面情绪的任务范围内，这些都是我们更有可能拖延的任务。所以当我们从情绪调节的角度来看待拖延时，
one way to think about is that we're not avoiding the task, per se. What we're avoiding is the negative emotions associated with that task. And so procrastination becomes a way to cope with that negative mood and those negative emotions, especially if you're someone who hasn't had a lot of experience managing your negative emotions effectively, or maybe you've got a lot of other stressors going on in your life that, you know, you've sort of your resources, your inner resources for coping with a task that might be really unpleasant or stressful or frustrating or creates a lot of worry for you. In those sorts of situations, you might resort to procrastination because what procrastination does is it gives you immediate relief. It's why we say it's sort of a short-term mood repair. It gives you that quick fix. So you take that task that's really stressing you out. You've got that report you've got to write. You're worried about what your manager is going to think because maybe, you know, promotion rides on it or you're worried with you're going to be doing it correctly or if you're going to do it just perfectly is what you
可以这样想：我们并不是在回避任务本身。我们回避的是与该任务相关的负面情绪。因此，拖延成为了一种应对那种负面情绪的方式，特别是如果你是一个没有太多有效管理负面情绪经验的人，或者你的生活中可能还有很多其他压力源，导致你应对可能非常令人不快、压力大、令人沮丧或让你产生很多担忧的任务的内在资源被耗尽了。在这种情况下，你可能会诉诸拖延，因为拖延能给你带来即时的缓解。这就是为什么我们说它是一种短期的情绪修复。它给你那种快速的解决方案。所以你把那个让你压力很大的任务拿走，你有那份必须写的报告。你担心经理会怎么想，因为可能升职取决于它，或者你担心自己是否能正确完成，或者如果你想做得完美，
want and you take that task, you put it aside and you get busy with other things, and you've now have this immediate sense of relief, you've actually just repaired that negative mood and you feel better. And the problem with that is it's immediately reinforcing. You get rewarded for doing that. And this is where some people can get caught in the trap of procrastination is almost a chronic habit or way of dealing with these unpleasant tasks. So yeah, that's how the emotions are involved.
你把那个任务放在一边，忙于其他事情，你现在有了一种即时的解脱感，你实际上刚刚修复了那种负面情绪，你感觉好多了。问题在于它是即时强化的。你因为这样做而得到了奖励。这就是为什么有些人会陷入拖延的陷阱，将其作为处理这些不愉快任务的一种慢性习惯或方式。所以是的，这就是情绪参与其中的方式。
It's really about the emotions that are associated with the task. And not necessarily the unpleasantness of the task, it doesn't have to be objectively an unpleasant task, but it's what our interaction with that task, you know, the emotions that arise from that interaction and how it makes us feel. And if it's something unpleasant and we can't quite work through those feelings, procrastination became a way to solve that, at least in the short run. So what are some strategies or techniques to combat procrastination and just get things done? And how does thinking of it as an emotion regulation problem change how we approach the situation?
这确实是关于与任务相关的情绪。并不一定非要是客观上不愉快的任务，它不一定非要是客观上令人不快的任务，而是我们与该任务的互动，即从这种互动中产生的情绪以及它让我们感觉如何。如果这是一件不愉快的事情，而我们无法完全克服这些感受，拖延就成为了一种解决方式，至少在短期内是这样。那么有哪些策略或技巧可以对抗拖延并把事情做完呢？将拖延视为一个情绪调节问题如何改变我们处理这种情况的方式？
Well, I think that's really key. If we want to address any type of problem, we've got to know what the core cause is. And if we, you know, coming at it from this mood regulation or motion regulation perspective, then what that suggests is that we need to find ways to make. those emotions first and foremost. And there's multiple layers of doing this. I think, you know, especially if it's a task that's really creating a lot of stress and really a little of frustration or anxiety or anticipated anxiety. Sometimes it's not how we feel right now, but we're anticipating that as soon as we, you know, start working on this task, we're going to get frustrated and
嗯，我认为这确实是关键。如果我们想解决任何类型的问题，我们必须知道核心原因是什么。如果我们从这种情绪调节的角度来看待它，那么这就意味着我们需要找到方法来首先处理这些情绪。这有多个层面。我认为，特别是如果这是一项确实会产生很大压力、挫败感、焦虑或预期焦虑的任务。有时不是我们现在的感觉，而是我们预料到一旦我们开始处理这项任务，我们就会感到沮丧，
that's enough to keep us from getting going with it. So, you know, finding ways to manage those negative motions, especially if they're really intense, is key. And some very simple ways, the research is borne out, you know, that takes sort of the edge off them is forgiveness and self-compassion. And it sounds counterintuitive because, you know, you know, collectively we like to think about, you know, sort of productivity and just, you know, crack the whip and get going. And if somebody is not being productive and procrastinating, we think if we push them harder and get on their case, then they'll actually be more productive rather than saying, hey, it's okay, you know, and taking more of a compassionate approach. And actually, um, the research suggests
这足以阻止我们开始工作。所以，找到管理这些负面情绪的方法，特别是如果它们非常强烈的话，是关键。研究证实了一些非常简单的方法，可以减轻它们的影响，那就是宽恕和自我同情。这听起来有悖常理，因为我们集体倾向于考虑生产力，只是鞭策自己动起来。如果有人没有效率并且在拖延，我们认为如果我们更严厉地对待他们，他们实际上会更有效率，而不是说，嘿，没关系，采取一种更具同情心的方法。实际上，研究表明
that those, both those approaches can be very beneficial. Forgiving, you know, students who forgave themselves for procrastinating on academic work were found two weeks later to actually procrastinate less. And we know that self-compassion is, can be a very powerful tool for regulating negative emotions. And that's another approach too, especially for really struggling and just say, you know, it's not giving yourself a free pass. It's basically saying, hey, yeah, I'm not, you know, I'm struggling with this task. I'm having difficulty. But you know what? It's okay. Other people have struggled with this task too. There's nothing special about my struggle. I just need to kind of work through that rather than, you know, getting hard on my, you know, getting hard on myself or beating myself up about this and making it worse, which actually can make it worse. The more that, you know, you get more critical about yourself about procrastinating, that can. can actually increase the chances that you'll continue to procrastinate. Right. You get into that endless feedback loop.
这两种方法都可以非常有益。那些原谅自己拖延学业的学生，两周后被发现实际上拖延得更少了。我们知道自我同情可以成为调节负面情绪的非常强大的工具。这也是另一种方法，特别是如果你真的在挣扎，只是说，嘿，这不是给自己开绿灯。这基本上是在说，嘿，是的，我正在为这项任务而挣扎。我有困难。但你知道吗？没关系。其他人也曾为这项任务而挣扎。我的挣扎没什么特别的。我只需要克服它，而不是对自己严厉或因为这件事而自责，这只会让事情变得更糟。你对自己拖延的批评越多，实际上越有可能增加你继续拖延的可能性。没错。你陷入了那种无休止的反馈循环。
Yeah, exactly. So how does chronic procrastination affect people's mental and physical well-being? Has a huge impact on it. And I think, you know, this is a thing a lot of people don't think about when they think about procrastination, right? We think about the immediate damage it can cause. So if you're a student and you procrastinating your academic work, then it's likely you're not going to do as well performance-wise. You're going to hand in things late and you're not going to do your
是的，完全正确。那么慢性拖延如何影响人们的身心健康？这对它有巨大的影响。我认为这是很多人在考虑拖延时不会想到的事情。我们考虑的是它可能造成的直接损害。所以如果你是一名学生，你在学业上拖延，那么你很可能在表现上不会那么好。你会迟交作业，也不会做出你最好的作品。
best work. And the research bears this out. You know, people, students who chronically procrastinate tend to have poor performance in terms of their grades. And in the workplace as well, people who chronically procrastinate or procrastinate regularly don't get, don't progress through their company as well. They tend to also have more insecure, you know, job status. In other they're jumping from job to job and they never really advance much. And they actually make less money than people who don't chronically procrastinate. And there's been some research on that. So we tend to think of the productivity side of it. But a lot of what my research has focused on over the last couple of decades is exactly what you said. There's these real health consequences.
研究证实了这一点。慢性拖延的学生在成绩方面往往表现较差。在职场中也是如此，慢性拖延或经常拖延的人在公司内部晋升得并不好。他们往往也有更不稳定的工作状态。换句话说，他们从一份工作跳到另一份工作，从未真正取得多大进展。而且他们赚的钱实际上比不慢性拖延的人少。对此已经有一些研究。所以我们倾向于考虑生产力方面。但我过去几十年的研究重点正是你所说的。有这些真实的健康后果。
Procrastination can be bad for your health. And so we know it's associated with, you know, higher rates of depression and anxiety, definitely higher rates of stress. That's one thing I found consistently, not just with students that I've done research with, but also adults out in the community. And it can have very real physical health effects. And this makes some sense if we think about how harmful stresses to our bodies, right? Not just it's harmful for our mental health. It's also harmful for our physical health. It has an impact on our immune system, makes us more vulnerable, you know, to catching bugs and flus and colds and all kinds of other stress-related illnesses. And this is something that I found in my own research to, students who chronically
拖延可能对你的健康有害。我们知道它与更高比例的抑郁和焦虑有关，绝对有更高比例的压力。这是我不仅在与我一起研究的学生中，而且在社区中的成年人中始终发现的一件事。它可能产生非常真实的身体健康影响。如果我们考虑到压力对我们身体的危害，这就有道理了，对吧？它不仅对我们的心理健康有害。它对我们的身体健康也有害。它对我们的免疫系统有影响，使我们更容易受到感染，更容易患上感冒、流感和各种其他与压力相关的疾病。这也是我在自己的研究中发现的，慢性拖延的学生
procrastinate tend to report more of these sort of stress-related, you know, mild health complaints. But they also can impact, you know, engaging in health behaviors. So if you're, you know, changing your diet, right, something that can be unpleasant, right? You have to give up some foods that you really enjoy, getting off the couch and away from the screen and getting out and doing physical exercise if you're not used to it, that can be unpleasant to start too. And so, you know, it's not surprising that we find that people chronically procrastinate also tend to put off engaging in those health-promoting behaviors that would really help their health overall. So if you put those two things together, higher stress, right, and poor health behaviors,
往往报告更多这类与压力相关的轻微健康问题。但它们也会影响参与健康行为。所以如果你正在改变你的饮食，这可能是不愉快的，对吧？你必须放弃一些你真正喜欢的食物，离开沙发和屏幕，出去进行体育锻炼，如果你不习惯的话，开始时也可能是不愉快的。所以，我们发现慢性拖延的人也倾向于推迟参与那些真正有助于他们整体健康的健康行为，这并不奇怪。所以如果你把这两件事放在一起，更高的压力和糟糕的健康行为，
and you tie that in with somebody who's got this pattern of dealing with unpleasant tasks in this very avoidant manner by procrastinating. Over time, there's going to be some cumulative damage. And although, you know, I've only done one study in this area, one study that I did do, looking at people with their heart health, so in terms of having hypertension or cardiovascular disease, I found that those who scored higher on a measure of chronic procrastination, when you controlled for all kinds of other factors that might account for poor heart health, you know, they were more likely to be in the group that had poor heart health. I think it worked out to the extent that they had a one point increase on this measure. So it was a self-report measure that we use.
并将这与一个以这种回避方式通过拖延来处理不愉快任务的人联系起来。随着时间的推移，会有一些累积的损害。虽然我只在这个领域做过一项研究，但我做过的一项研究是观察人们的心脏健康，即患有高血压或心血管疾病的情况，我发现那些在慢性拖延量表上得分较高的人，在控制了所有其他可能导致心脏健康状况不佳的因素后，他们更有可能属于心脏健康状况不佳的群体。我认为这相当于他们在该量表上每增加一分。所以这是一个我们使用的自我报告量表。
We ask people about, you know, how often they procrastinate or if they're putting things off to tomorrow. So for every one point's increase on that measure, their chances of having poor heart health increased by 63%. And that's after accounting for a lot of other factors. Wow. Yeah. But, you know, it makes sense, too, because if you're stressed all the time and you're not looking after your health, these healthy behaviors, and stress and health behaviors are two key pathways to good health, and when you don't engage, and then we know that they are risk factors for poor heart health. So, you know, I mean, I think that's kind of, you know, the extreme case over several decades. So there's short-term health impacts, but there's also some more
我们询问人们关于他们拖延的频率，或者他们是否把事情推迟到明天。所以该量表每增加一分，他们心脏健康状况不佳的几率就会增加 63%。这是在考虑了许多其他因素之后。哇。是的，但这也说得通，因为如果你一直处于压力之下，又不照顾自己的健康，压力和健康行为是通向良好健康的两个关键途径，而当你没有参与其中时，我们知道它们是心脏健康状况不佳的风险因素。所以，我认为这在几十年里属于极端情况。所以有短期的健康影响，但也有一些更
serious long-term health impacts as well. So a moment ago you mentioned the couch and the screen being able to get away from those things. I'm wondering whether you know, does the ubiquity of social media and electronic devices have an impact on procrastination or have procrastinators always been able to find excuses to put things off? That's a great question. You know, there's some procrastination research that looked just at that, just looked at, you know, sort of social media and digital distractions. And that's their whole research program is in that area.
严重的长期健康影响。刚才你提到了沙发和屏幕，能够远离这些东西。我想知道，社交媒体和电子设备的普及是否对拖延有影响，还是说拖延者一直都能找到借口推迟事情？这是一个很好的问题。有一些拖延研究专门研究了这一点，研究了社交媒体和数字干扰。这就是他们在该领域的研究项目。
And there is indeed a connection. So people who are prone to procrastination do tend to use more social media, tend to be, you know, engage with their digital distractions. And, you know, there might be some generational influences there too, right? But that being said, you know, there's other things that we can do to engage in procrastination for sure. And if you look at something like bedtime procrastination, which is a particular form of procrastination where you say, hey, I've got an important meeting tomorrow morning. I'm going to go to bed at 11 o'clock.
确实存在联系。所以容易拖延的人确实倾向于使用更多的社交媒体，倾向于沉迷于他们的数字干扰。而且，这可能也有一些代际影响，对吧？话虽如此，我们肯定还有其他事情可以做来参与拖延。如果你看看像睡前拖延，这是一种特殊的拖延形式，你说，嘿，我明天早上有个重要的会议。我 11 点要睡觉。
And here we are 1 a.m. in the morning and you're still on your social media. You know, or you may be sitting. up reading that novel or you may be knitting that sweater. So the researchers that have looked at what people do to procrastinate on their bedtimes, it's not just digitally oriented distractions. They engage in a whole bunch of things. Some of them bake even. I mean, it's really bizarre. So I think it's, you know, whatever your fancy is, right? You know, it's something to distract you from the emotions that you're not dealing with about the tasks that you should be doing, which is going to bad, right? And maybe it's because you, you know, you haven't processed what went on in that day.
结果现在是凌晨 1 点，你还在刷社交媒体。或者你可能坐在那里读那本小说，或者你可能在织那件毛衣。所以研究人们在睡前拖延做什么的研究人员发现，这不仅仅是数字导向的干扰。他们参与了各种各样的事情。有些人甚至烘焙。我的意思是，这真的很奇怪。所以我认为，无论你喜欢什么，对吧？这都是为了分散你对那些你本该做的事情（即睡觉）所涉及的情绪的注意力，对吧？也许是因为你还没有处理好那天发生的事情。
But, you know, that, again, it's an emotion regulation issue. And I think, yeah, the digital media makes it easier for certain generations. And I think that other generations might equally find other, you know, types of distractions and activities to engage in. In fact, anecdotally, a lot of the people I've talked to, when I say I do procrastination research, I get a lot of people telling me about the procrastination story. So you hear a lot of different things. And, you know, I remember there was one journalist I spoke to, and he said, yeah, I remember, you know, when I was a student in university. And, you know, I hate cleaning. I hate cleaning house. But whenever I had a big paper or exam coming, boy, was my house ever clean. So, you know, instead of doing studying, he was running around, getting, you know, the house perfectly clean. And you see this a lot. It's not like procrastinator is sitting around lazy. They're doing other things. It's just not that thing.
但是，这又是一个情绪调节问题。我认为，是的，数字媒体让某些世代更容易拖延。我认为其他世代可能同样会找到其他类型的干扰和活动来参与。事实上，轶事上，我交谈过的很多人，当我说我做拖延研究时，很多人会告诉我他们的拖延故事。所以你会听到很多不同的事情。我记得我采访过一位记者，他说，是的，我记得我上大学的时候。我讨厌打扫卫生。我讨厌打扫房子。但每当我有一篇大论文或考试要来时，天哪，我的房子总是打扫得干干净净。所以，他没有去学习，而是在到处跑，把房子打扫得一尘不染。你经常看到这种情况。拖延者并不是坐在那里懒惰。他们在做其他事情。只是不是那件
that they should be doing right now. That's looming and important and will have negative consequences if they don't get it done. In prepping for this conversation, I of course had to go to Dr. Google and find out who are famous procrastinators. And there are lists, so you've probably seen them. And they include luminaries like the Dalai Lama, Frank Lloyd Wright, Herman Melville, Leonardo da Vinci. Putting aside whether these lists are historically accurate, they raise the question, is it possible to be a chronic procrastinator, but also extremely productive? That is a really good question. And I think, yeah, I mean, I would go back to, well, were they really procrastinating or were
他们现在应该做的、迫在眉睫且重要的事情，如果不完成就会产生负面后果。在准备这次谈话时，我当然不得不去谷歌博士那里查谁是著名的拖延者。有很多名单，所以你可能见过它们。其中包括像达赖喇嘛、弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特、赫尔曼·梅尔维尔、列奥纳多·达·芬奇这样的名人。撇开这些名单在历史上是否准确不谈，它们提出了一个问题：一个人既是慢性拖延者，又极其高效，这可能吗？这是一个非常好的问题。我想，我会回到，他们是真的在拖延，还是
they engaging in some other form of delay? You know, so we talk about sagacious delay where on the surface, when somebody put something off, we might look at them and say, hey, they're procrastinating. Or we might even look at our own behavior. And just because it's a delay and we're not doing what we know we should be doing, we might say, well, I'm procrastinating. But if you sort of look below the surface, it may be that maybe you haven't started that report because you're waiting to hear back with some key information that's essential for you to get going on this. And if you started without that information, you actually would be wasting a lot of time, right?
他们在参与某种其他形式的延迟？我们谈论的是明智的延迟，表面上，当某人推迟某事时，我们可能会看着他们说，嘿，他们在拖延。或者我们甚至可能审视我们自己的行为。仅仅因为这是一种延迟，而我们没有做我们知道应该做的事情，我们可能会说，我在拖延。但如果你看看表面之下，可能你还没有开始那份报告，因为你在等待一些对你开始工作至关重要的关键信息。如果你在没有这些信息的情况下开始，你实际上会浪费很多时间，对吧？
And so I think we really do have to make that distinction between delay and procrastination. There might be some really, you know, monumental delays out there, but they could be sagacious delays, wise delays who are doing it with purpose. Yeah, and I think the people that I've spoken to who really struggle with procrastination, they are in a bad way. They have career issues, health issues. They're not fulfilling their dreams. They're not reaching their goals. So, you know, rather than frame it in terms of productivity, which I think feeds into a lot of our social norms about who we, you know, what we shouldn't shouldn't be doing and how much we shouldn't be doing, I'd rather frame it around people's, you know, whether you're reaching your goals or not. Or do you have all these things you started and never finished?
所以我认为我们确实必须区分延迟和拖延。可能存在一些非常重大的延迟，但它们可能是明智的延迟，是有目的的延迟。是的，我认为我交谈过的那些真正与拖延作斗争的人，他们的处境很糟糕。他们有职业问题、健康问题。他们没有实现自己的梦想。他们没有达到自己的目标。所以，与其从生产力的角度来框架它，我认为这助长了我们许多关于我们应该做什么、不应该做什么以及我们应该做多少的社会规范，我宁愿围绕人们是否达到了他们的目标来框架它。或者你是否有很多开始后从未完成的事情？
Do you have all these unfulfilled goals that you just never got around to doing because fear or failure or just worried it wasn't going to be good enough or worried whether you could manage maybe some of the challenges that you might face when you engage with that task? Given that these famous alleged procrastinators maybe weren't procrastinators at all, I thought it was interesting that there weren't a lot of women on the lists that I saw. A couple of names popped up, Margaret Atwood, J.K. Rowling, for example, who are also highly productive. But should we take that to mean, if there's any truth to these lists at all, that women procrastinate less than men? So that's a great question. It's a little bit controversial. So the evidence, it's a little mixed. A lot of studies haven't found any difference.
你是否有很多未实现的目标，仅仅因为恐惧、失败或担心不够好，或者担心当你处理该任务时可能面临的一些挑战，而从未着手去做？鉴于这些著名的所谓拖延者可能根本不是拖延者，我觉得有趣的是，我看到的名单上女性并不多。出现了几个名字，例如玛格丽特·阿特伍德、J.K.罗琳，她们也是高效的。但如果这些名单有任何真实性的话，我们是否应该认为女性比男性拖延得少？这是一个很好的问题。这有点争议。证据有点复杂。许多研究没有发现任何差异。
And since some more recent evidence does suggest that men tend to. procrastinate a little bit more than women. So, and often it depends on the measures that you're using as well. And I guess here we're talking about chronic procrastination as opposed to sort of, you know, procrastinating from time to time. So yeah, I would say there's, there is some evidence suggests men might procrastinate a little bit more than women. But it's not a huge difference. And we may get some evidence in the coming years that that levels out because I think it is really driven also by what's going on, you know, just coming out of the situation we're coming out of now, what more people working from home and having to deal with a lot of distractions they didn't
一些较新的证据确实表明男性倾向于比女性拖延得更多一点。所以，这通常也取决于你使用的衡量标准。我想在这里我们谈论的是慢性拖延，而不是偶尔的拖延。所以是的，我会说有一些证据表明男性可能比女性拖延得更多一点。但差异并不大。我们可能会在未来几年得到一些证据表明这种情况会趋于平缓，因为我认为这确实也受到正在发生的事情的驱动，刚刚走出我们现在所处的环境，更多的人在家工作，不得不处理他们以前不需要处理的许多干扰。
have to deal with before. I think that would kind of level the playing field for many people as well in terms of, you know, whether they were able to be productive or whether they found themselves falling into a trap of procrastination. Well, somewhat related to my last question, are there cultural differences among people who procrastinate. For example, there's some countries where deadlines are loose, trains and planes don't run on fixed schedules. And then there are other countries where efficiency and productivity are highly valued. So are we all in some sense a product of our culture when it comes to procrastination? The best way to answer that, and I do agree, there are there's different cultural norms, if you like, and sort of just unspoken standards about
我认为这在生产力方面或他们是否发现自己陷入了拖延的陷阱方面，对许多人来说会拉平竞争环境。好吧，与我的上一个问题有些相关，拖延者之间是否存在文化差异？例如，有些国家的截止日期很宽松，火车和飞机不按固定时间表运行。而另一些国家则高度重视效率和生产力。那么在拖延方面，我们是否在某种意义上都是文化的产物？回答这个问题的最好方法是，我确实同意，存在不同的文化规范，如果你愿意的话，以及关于
you know what is and isn't acceptable you know across different countries in different parts of the world I would think that it's more about it's not necessarily that you would procrastinate more or less necessarily depending on what the restraints were on if you were if it was a country where you know the tolerance for procrastination was quite low that might certainly have an impact but I think it's about the acceptability as well so and you know there is some research there's some procrastination researchers down in Peru and we do these conferences every couple of years
什么可以接受、什么不可以接受的潜规则，在世界各地的不同国家。我认为这更多是关于，并不一定取决于限制是什么，你就会拖延更多或更少。如果这是一个对拖延的容忍度很低的国家，那肯定会有影响，但我认为这也关乎可接受性。而且，有一些研究，秘鲁有一些拖延研究人员，我们每隔几年就会举办这些会议，
and just sort of international conference on procrastination and we hear about the different research that's going on different parts of the world on the topic of procrastination and one of the researchers there, she mentioned that, you know, especially in the workplace, you know, in Peru, it's like people procrastinate quite regularly because they see their managers and their bosses procrastinating. So it sets a standard and everyone thinks it's okay.
关于拖延的国际会议，我们听到了世界各地关于拖延主题的不同研究。其中一位研究人员提到，特别是在职场中，在秘鲁，人们经常拖延，因为他们看到他们的经理和老板在拖延。所以它设定了一个标准，每个人都认为这没问题。
But there's tolerance for it too. So there's not so much as a strong response to procrastination in cultures where things are a little bit more lax in terms of timelines. And I think it has to do with deadlines and how flexible those are. Then you go to other parts of the world and one part of the world where there's actually quite a booming research or culture of researchers looking into procrastination, that's Germany. And again, we think of, you know, Germany is being highly efficient, you know, trains running on time and everything sort of very precise. And the tolerance there for procrastination is quite low. And that's probably why there's a lot of research into it there too.
但也有对它的容忍度。所以在时间表方面比较宽松的文化中，对拖延的反应并不那么强烈。我认为这与截止日期以及它们的灵活性有关。然后你去世界的其他地方，有一个地方实际上有相当蓬勃的研究或研究人员文化在研究拖延，那就是德国。同样，我们认为德国是高效的，火车准时，一切都非常精确。那里对拖延的容忍度很低。这可能就是那里有很多关于它的研究的原因。
But I remember some years back at one of our conferences, we had some students presenting posters about their research on procrastination. And there was this, what did they call it? They called it a procrastination ambulance, which was, I think, their way of terms. translating saying it was like a clinic for procrastination at a university for students who were really troubled by their procrastination. So they could come in, engage in this program over a few weeks that would help reduce their procrastination. And, you know, they showed the data suggesting that their program worked and they showed the sort of the mean scores on this measure of chronic procrastination at the beginning of, you know, them coming to the clinic and at the end so they could
但我记得几年前在我们的一次会议上，我们有一些学生展示了关于他们拖延研究的海报。有一个，他们称之为什么？他们称之为拖延救护车，我认为这是他们翻译的一种方式，说这就像大学里为那些真正被拖延困扰的学生设立的拖延诊所。所以他们可以进来，在几周内参与这个项目，这将有助于减少他们的拖延。而且，他们展示的数据表明他们的项目有效，他们展示了在来到诊所开始时和结束时，在这个慢性拖延量表上的平均得分，所以他们可以
say, oh, look, there's some improvement. And I remember standing there with a colleague of mine, and we both were looking at the scores on this measure of procrastination at time one. And the level of procrastination that they found troubling was well below the average national mean for the procrastination in the U.S. and Canada. But this was troubling in Germany. In Canada, U.S., it would have been, that's not an issue. Yeah, I could see that. Yeah.
说，哦，看，有一些改善。我记得我和我的一位同事站在那里，我们都在看时间 1 时这个拖延量表上的分数。他们发现令人困扰的拖延程度远低于美国和加拿大拖延的全国平均水平。但这在德国是令人困扰的。在加拿大、美国，那根本不是问题。是的，我能理解。是的。
So, yeah, I think, and this is my saying, sort of the tolerance for procrastination, I think, differs. across different cultural contexts. You also study perfectionism, which is a topic that we recently talked about on another episode of this podcast. I just want to ask if perfectionism and procrastination are linked and are perfectionists more or less likely to procrastinate? Great question. Yeah.
所以，是的，我认为，这就是我的说法，对拖延的容忍度在不同的文化背景下是不同的。你还研究完美主义，这是我们在这个播客的另一集中最近讨论过的话题。我只是想问完美主义和拖延是否有关联，完美主义者是否更有可能或更不可能拖延？很好的问题。是的。
And I think, you know, first thing I have to say is that perfectionism isn't sort of a single entity. We have these sort of different subcategories or dimensions of perfectionism. So there's this thing called perfectionistic concerns, which is sort of a self-critical type of perfectionism, where the person has really high, you know, standards for themselves and is really driven to try and please other people. And, you know, their self-worth is contingent upon whether they live up to some sort of idealized standard that they think society or their friends or their family expect of them. And then you've got this other flavor of perfectionism, which is this perfectionistic strivings, which is more someone who's, you're not. driven by their own internal standards, but these standards are still quite high. And so because of that, they might sort of not be able to savor their successes when they actually reach those standards.
首先我要说的是，完美主义并不是一个单一的实体。我们有这些完美主义的子类别或维度。有一种东西叫做完美主义关注，这是一种自我批评式的完美主义，一个人对自己有非常高的标准，并且非常有动力去取悦他人。而且，他们的自我价值取决于他们是否达到了他们认为社会、朋友或家人期望他们的某种理想标准。然后你有另一种完美主义，即完美主义追求，这更多是一个人，你不是被自己的内部标准所驱动，但这些标准仍然相当高。因此，由于这个原因，当他们真正达到这些标准时，他们可能无法享受他们的成功。
And so we actually conducted some research a couple years ago where we did this thing called a meta-analysis, which is basically a review of all the research has ever been done looking at the associations between perfectionism, both perfectionism dimensions there, and procrastination. And we had, you know, 40 some odd studies that included 10,000 people. And when we looked at the links between chronic procrastination and perfectionism, we indeed found that individuals who were more prone to chronic procrastination also scored higher on this measure of the self-critical perfectionism. However, there wasn't a link with the other form of perfectionism. So I sort of lay that out there because it's slightly different there.
几年前我们进行了一些研究，做了一个所谓的元分析，基本上就是回顾了以往所有关于完美主义（包括完美主义的两个维度）与拖延症之间关联的研究。我们分析了40多项研究，涵盖了1万人。当我们观察慢性拖延与完美主义之间的联系时，我们确实发现，那些更容易出现慢性拖延的人，在自我批判型完美主义的量表上也得分更高。然而，这种联系在另一种完美主义形式中并不存在。我之所以提出这一点，是因为它们之间存在细微差别。
I can say yes and no because no to one type, but yes to another. And I think it makes sense, though, too, because if you're really driven and your whole sense of self-worth is focused on how well you do this task and you're so worried about that task, that's enough. That fear of failing, that fear of it not being good enough or not pleasing others can be enough to put you off ever even starting it. And the other thing that happens, too, when you don't start a task, you can still live in that wonderful, space, right, where you can imagine how great it's going to be. And you can picture how perfect the ending is going to be when you finish, you know, writing that report or, you know, redecorating your house or whatever it is at that task that you're dealing with at that time. But in minutes you take action and start to encounter problems, which we all do, right? It's never a
我可以说是，也可以说不是，因为对于一种类型来说不是，但对于另一种来说是。我认为这很有道理，因为如果你非常有动力，并且你全部的自我价值感都集中在你完成这项任务的好坏上，而且你对这项任务感到非常焦虑，这就足够了。那种对失败的恐惧，那种担心做得不够好或无法取悦他人的恐惧，足以让你甚至不想开始。还有一件事，当你还没开始一项任务时，你仍然可以生活在那种美妙的空间里，在那里你可以想象它会变得多么棒。你可以想象当你完成那份报告、重新装饰房子或者处理当时手头的任何任务时，结局会是多么完美。但一旦你采取行动并开始遇到问题（我们都会遇到），几分钟内，它就再也不是
straight direct path from point A to point B when we're trying to reach our goals. There's ups and downs along the way. But people who are, you know, have these sort of self-critical perfectionism, the minute they hit one of those bumps in the road, so we speak, on the path to their goal, they give up, right? They have a zero tolerance sort of policy for any sort of mistakes or anything not going correctly. And so they tap out. And then, yeah, what we see that as procrastination. Procrastination has to be a tough thing to study in a lab. How do you do that? I mean, if you bring people in to be observed and to be experimental subjects, what do you tell them to procrastinate? I mean, how do you do this? The quick answer is, you can't. You actually can't because, you know,
从A点到B点的直线路径。当我们试图实现目标时，总会有起起落落。但是那些有这种自我批判型完美主义的人，一旦在实现目标的道路上遇到所谓的障碍，他们就会放弃。他们对任何错误或任何进展不顺利的情况都有零容忍政策。所以他们就退出了。然后，是的，我们将其视为拖延。在实验室里研究拖延症一定很难。你怎么做呢？我的意思是，如果你把人带进来观察并作为实验对象，你告诉他们去拖延吗？我的意思是，你怎么做？简单的回答是，你做不到。你实际上做不到，因为，你知道，
if we look at the definition, it's got to be something they intended to do. We can't impose that on them. I mean, that being said, there has been some experimental research done where they gave, you know, students a range of tasks easy and more difficult and looked at the time on task and what things they did otherwise. But that's the closest we can get to it. And so this is one of the reasons why, you know, at least with my research anyways, what I've defaulted to is looking at people who have a chronic tendency to procrastinate. Because that's in a sense like we're holding that, you know, procrastination constant. And we're looking at what are the sort of thoughts that they have.
如果我们看定义，那必须是他们打算做的事情。我们不能强加给他们。话虽如此，确实有一些实验研究，给学生布置了一系列简单和困难的任务，并观察他们在任务上花费的时间以及他们还做了什么。但这已经是我们能做到的最接近的方法了。这就是为什么，至少在我的研究中，我默认的方法是观察那些有慢性拖延倾向的人。因为在某种意义上，我们保持了拖延的恒定性，并观察他们有什么样的想法。
What are the sort of, you know, consequences that they experience, right? And so, and then, you know, I also studying it naturalistically. So recording behavior. So some of my students have looked at, you know, getting people to answer some questionnaires at one time point. And then following up with them and getting to fill in with grids, you know, based on, you know, 30-minute or 15-minute segments of the day, were you procrastinating in that time. And then we do a bit of a calculation to get an idea of how many minutes they were procrastinating. So it's much easier to study it in sort of a naturalistic setting by just getting people to self-report or to look at people who,
他们经历了什么样的后果，对吧？所以，我也在自然环境下研究它。也就是记录行为。我的一些学生曾让人们在某个时间点回答一些问卷。然后进行后续追踪，让他们填写表格，根据一天中30分钟或15分钟的时间段，记录你当时是否在拖延。然后我们进行一些计算，以了解他们拖延了多少分钟。因此，通过让人们进行自我报告，或者观察那些
chronically procrastinate because what you're studying the lab is going to be delay for sure, but it isn't necessarily going to be procrastination, and that is a real challenge. So last question. What are you working on now? What are the next things that you're looking at in the realm of procrastination or even the other areas where you're doing research? Great. Yeah, I'm doing a few different things. So one of the projects I want to look at, I know there was this type of work that was done with perfectionism showing that perfectionism is increasing over time. So I'm curious to know whether rates of procrastination over the last couple decades are increasing over time as well. So that's one project that I'll be working on and we're looking at sort of existing research out there to see if the mean levels of procrastination, chronic procrastination that is, have gone up, especially in student samples over the last couple of decades.
长期拖延的人，在自然环境下研究它要容易得多，因为你在实验室里研究的肯定是延迟，但不一定是拖延，这是一个真正的挑战。最后一个问题。你现在在研究什么？在拖延症领域，或者你正在研究的其他领域，你接下来关注的是什么？太好了。是的，我正在做几件不同的事情。其中一个项目我想研究的是，我知道之前有关于完美主义的研究表明，完美主义随着时间的推移在增加。所以我很好奇，过去几十年来拖延症的发生率是否也在增加。所以这是我将要研究的一个项目，我们正在查看现有的研究，看看拖延症，也就是慢性拖延症的平均水平是否有所上升，特别是在过去几十年的学生样本中。
The other areas I'm looking at is trying to get a handle on some of, you know, what's happening with respect to the emotion regulation. And specifically, you know, this idea that we tend to often not get started on a task because we make emotional mountains out of molehills, right? So there's this task, we may not have enough information about it, and we start imagining how difficult it's going to be and how complex is going to be and how complex is going to be. and how we're going to fail or struggle. And that's enough to keep us from actually getting started on the task. And this sort of fits in with an area of research that's called effective forecasting, which basically says that as human beings, we're not very good at predicting our future emotional states. And I think this happens a lot with procrastination, that we predict that we're going to feel a lot worse
我关注的另一个领域是试图弄清楚情绪调节方面正在发生什么。具体来说，就是我们往往因为把小事化大而无法开始一项任务的想法，对吧？所以有这样一个任务，我们可能没有足够的信息，然后我们开始想象它会有多困难，会有多复杂，以及我们将如何失败或挣扎。这足以阻止我们真正开始这项任务。这与一个被称为“情感预测”的研究领域相吻合，该领域基本上说，作为人类，我们不太擅长预测我们未来的情绪状态。我认为这在拖延症中经常发生，我们预测我们会感觉更糟
when we're doing the task than when we actually get on and just do it. And we also think that it's going to last longer. We're going to be stuck in the state of frustration or stress or what have you as we're struggling with this task. And, you know, push comes to shove and we actually do it. It's like, wait a second, that actually wasn't very hard at all. And it was a lot faster to get through than what I expected. But there isn't a lot of research on that. So that's conducting some experiments now to see if, you know, maybe people prone to procrastination are over, you know, anticipating how difficult that task is going to be.
当我们做任务时，比我们真正开始做的时候要糟。我们也认为它会持续更长时间。当我们与这项任务作斗争时，我们会陷入沮丧或压力的状态，等等。然后，你知道，当真正去做的时候，就像，等一下，那其实一点也不难。而且完成的速度比我预期的要快得多。但关于这方面的研究并不多。所以我现在正在进行一些实验，看看那些容易拖延的人是否可能高估了任务的难度。
So just sort of drilling down into understanding better, that emotional side. And then some of the other work I'm doing is just, again, trying to maybe get some more hard indicators of the health effects. So actually looking at more objective measures, you know, you're looking using sort of like smart watches, right, to track people's behavior, their physical activity, and seeing, again, if in fact, you know, people who are prone to procrastination are actually being less active than others.
所以只是深入挖掘以更好地理解情感方面。我正在做的其他一些工作是，再次尝试获得一些关于健康影响的更硬性的指标。所以实际上是看更客观的衡量标准，你知道，使用智能手表之类的东西来追踪人们的行为、他们的身体活动，看看是否确实，那些容易拖延的人实际上比其他人更不活跃。
Oh, and I'll mention one final thing, too. I've done some preliminary work looking at using self-compassion to address procrastination, and it does suggest that it at least increases people's intentions to get on with the task and not procrastinate, but I want to follow up with some research to actually track that. So if we tell people to recall a time that they're procrastinating and then give them this sort of script that reframes that experience in a self-compassionate manner, you know, basically you're not the first person to procrastinate, nor will you be the last, right? So, you know, get over it, get on with it and move forward, right? Then, you know, does that actually have an impact on their ability to, you know, stop procrastinating and get things done? Well, that's some good advice for you procrastinators who are listening to us today. Just do it and you'll feel a lot better than you think you will. Well, I want to thank you for joining me today, Dr. Sirwa.
哦，我还要提最后一件事。我做了一些初步工作，研究使用自我同情来解决拖延问题，这确实表明它至少增加了人们开始任务而不拖延的意图，但我想要进行一些后续研究来实际追踪这一点。所以如果我们告诉人们回忆一次他们拖延的时候，然后给他们这种以自我同情的方式重构该经历的脚本，你知道，基本上你不是第一个拖延的人，也不会是最后一个，对吧？所以，你知道，克服它，继续前进，对吧？那么，这是否真的对他们停止拖延和完成事情的能力产生影响？好吧，这对今天听我们节目的拖延者来说是一些好的建议。去做吧，你会感觉比你想象的要好得多。好吧，我要感谢你今天加入我，Sirwa博士。
I'm so glad that we did not put off this discussion. Myself as well. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.spicingsofteorg or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology. at APA.org.
我很高兴我们没有推迟这次讨论。我也是。谢谢你邀请我。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们 SpeakingofPsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Condihan。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。